voilà le dernier morceau c'était get my
party
extrait de l'album lucky day sur lequel
il y avait des gens et sexy lady l'album
précédent de Shaggy Hot Shot avec
itoisons me c'est vendu à 10 millions de
millions de moins que Dido 10 millions
d'exemplaires dans le monde voilà
shaggy c'est dommage qu'avec les filles
vous vous soyez un petit peu calmé parce
qu'avec tous ces succès ce serait ça
serait énorme c'est
il y a des très belles femmes ici il y a
des moches aussi
[Applaudissements]
par jour c'est vrai c'est 5 ou 6 pour
mettre Collard
sans
qu'est-ce qui vous dit que je me suis
calmé d'ailleurs
non on m'a dit que vous aviez une
amoureuse maintenant vous étiez assez
sage non
mais c'était à 2h
en tous les cas on peut dire que vous
avez une vraie nature de de jamaïcain
c'est-à-dire que vous êtes très
intéressé par les femmes bien ça c'est
vrai
[Applaudissements]
ça fait trois mois
de jamaïcain né à Kingston son vrai nom
c'est Orville Richard beurrel on l'a
surnommé shaggy à cause au départ du
dessin animé Scooby-Doo en français le
personnage s'appelle Sami mais quand
vous découvrez quand vous découvrez
l'Angleterre shaggy vous découvrez que
tout chaque Casimir oui mais il découvre
en arrivant en Angleterre
et c'est vrai sérieusement pour choper
des filles c'est mieux de s'appeler
shaggy que en ville
cela étant
quand on m'appelle shaggy comme ça au
début je me suis dit c'est peut-être pas
un nom très sympa parce que ça fait
penser à un chien mais en fait
effectivement en arrivant en Angleterre
j'ai vu qu'il y avait des connotations
sympas c'est comme ça que j'ai pu
ramasser des filles et je sais Monsieur
monsieur le buzzer
tu sais que c'est un homme à femme il a
besoin d'être entouré s'il y a pas une
femme qui le caresse un petit peu
pendant qu'il parle il se dit pas au
mieux de sa forme
c'est un Jamaïcain il a ça dans le sang
soit minimum réceptives quand même
comment on fait comment on fait pour
être chanteur pour avoir trois femmes
comme ça par soir comment c'est quoi
je comprends pas
français quand tu les fais rire et que
tu chantes c'est le maximum que tu peux
faire et quand tu vends c'est encore
mieux
quand tu écoutes j'entends pas et quand
tu écoutes c'est bien en fait en fait je
veux dire la meilleure façon d'y prendre
c'est d'avoir des grosses choses sur une
grosse pointue
est-ce qu'on pourrait un peu parler
musique merde
je suis en train de devenir un peu fou
moi là parce qu'il était en train de
dire là c'est qu'il est monté comme un
âne
ça va nous passer
alors donc shaggy à l'âge de 18 ans vous
quittez la Jamaïque vous partez à New
York avec votre maman et deux ans plus
tard
vous trouvez pas de travail vous avez
peur de mal tourner dans les rues de de
Brooklyn et vous vous engagez dans les
Marines voilà alors quand vous engagez
dans les Marines vous avez aucune idée
de ce qui vous attend vous voyez un
petit peu ça comme une colonie de
vacances et vous vous retrouvez au front
guerdirac trompette du désert c'est le
mec dans un coup il se retrouve là-bas
ça peut être trois fois la même
voir le
ça peut être effectivement trois fois le
même allez on lui donne la lettre
sérieusement
sérieusement quand vous êtes retrouvés
dans Tempête du désert ça doit être
horrible pour vous non
c'était absolument terrible
je sais pas parti pour faire la guerre
je comptais revenir en un seul morceau
c'était mon idée j'ai tous mes pieds
j'ai tous mes mains mes doigts c'est ce
qu'il me faut
tout à l'heure il a dit et l'autre a dit
oui c'est vrai et après tout à l'heure
c'est qui le traducteur là
je peux pas lui en vouloir je l'aime
beaucoup c'est un des meilleurs
traducteurs qu'on est ici Robert
merci c'est gentil c'est gentil
dans l'armée ils passent 20 ans sans
faire de guerre et c'est vrai que vous
vous engagez pour pour 4 ans et tout de
suite c'est la guerre il y a
beaucoup de malchance alors quand shaggy
parle de la guerre d'Irak la première la
guerre du Golfe il dit les gisements de
pétrole brûlés on ne voyait rien on se
réveillait le matin couvert de suinois
c'est un petit peu Fabrice à Waterloo
c'est à dire que c'est au milieu comme
ça de vous comprenez pas ce qui se passe
en fait Fabrice comment me demande
delongo
effectivement c'était assez dur on se
réveille le matin on arrivait même pas
d'avoir ses mains au bout de son nez et
évidemment c'est comme ça qu'on apprécie
la vie qu'on apprécie d'être en ville
quand on se lève le matin il y a
beaucoup de choses qu'on trouve normal
bien souvent c'est le matin on se lève
on fait pas son lit on trouve ça normal
mais là on ira qu'on a même pas de ligue
à faire alors tout d'un coup tout est
changé toutes les choses lequel on est
habitué on ne les a plus on se trouve au
milieu du désert mais rien du tout et là
on se rend compte qu'on apprécie ce
qu'on a chez soi les petites choses un
décalage tu es resté dans le désert
à peu près 6 mois mais quand tu es dans
le désert le plus trop longtemps
c'est que certains étaient là-bas pour
faire la guerre vraiment pour se battre
vous en fait votre seul objectif c'était
de rentrer en un seul morceau
j'étais un gamin je venais de Jamaïque
j'étais en fait un immigré jamaïcain qui
est arrivé à New York un flat bouche bon
moi je voulais pas traîner dans les rues
je voulais faire l'armée pour me on m'a
dit que si j'allais faire la messe je
m'en sortais parce que tous mes boulots
je me faisais virer systématiquement là
là je trouvais un boulot vous n'allez
pas me virer l'armée alors je me suis
dit bon je pourrais m'en sortir sans
problème et manque de pots il y a eu la
guerre et puis il y avait deux
possibilités soit j'allais sur le front
ou alors ou alors j'étais en cabane pour
version alors j'avais pas le choix je
suis allé faire la guerre l'idée c'était
comme j'ai dit revenir en un seul
morceau moi j'aime l'amour pas la guerre
vous avez gagné votre guerre parce que
finalement c'était votre objectif
revenir entier sérieusement à chaque
niveau vous pensez que que cette fois-ci
en tous les cas quand les Américains
sont retournés en Irak l'année dernière
quoi c'est c'était quand même un petit
peu précipité
je trouve qu'effectivement
la guerre doit être le dernier recours
par exemple de la première guerre du
Golf on dit que c'était une guerre avec
un minimum de minimum de dégâts en fait
quand vous avez un père une mère une un
frère qui meurt c'est pas c'est pas des
petits dégâts c'est des c'est une grosse
paire donc ça doit vraiment être un
dernier recours donc les Américains dit
shaggy ont agi un petit peu
précipitamment vous avez ramené quoi
comme souvenir du covidence
et vous avez laissé des enfants derrière
vous Auvergne
[Rires]
vous aviez quel grade ce guide
à propos j'étais pas à Marine Modene je
me suis fait virer pratiquement j'étais
sous offre sous-officier au bout de
quatre ans c'est tout ce que j'ai pu
faire j'étais un le dernier de la classe
en quelque sorte vous avez pas été vous
avez pas été décoré
et puis le problème c'est parce que je
suivais mal les ordres et même à ce jour
je déshabille toujours donc vous n'êtes
pas un héros de la guerre du Golfe
absolument pas donc j'ai été sur est-ce
que vous avez chanté dans le désert pour
les GI
ah voilà ce que je fais c'est du reggae
donc c'est une espèce de une forme
reggae de chanson alors quand je le
faisais personne ne comprenait les
paroles de mes chansons
en anglais on comprend pas tous non plus
les paroles des chansons on aime bien
du moment où vous achetez les disques
c'est dans les Marines s'il y a un truc
qui est sœur yes
alors on va faire une petite interview
comme ça ça y est ça alors soldat comme
ça maintenant vous faites de la chanson
serait ça pourquoi avoir choisi ce
métier de la chanson soldat parce que
tu en es un
océan
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu